now to a story involving someone close
to the president the Secret Service is
investigating an extraordinary security
breach last month when a man invaded
agents and broke into the home of Jake
Sullivan President Biden's National
Security adviser senior investigative
correspondent Catherine Herridge is in
Washington Catherine good morning good
morning Nate sources channel CBS News
investigators are a scouring grainy
video that may show the Intruder outside
Sullivan's home U.S law enforcement
officials confirmed the man slipped past
at least three Secret Service agents and
threw the robust security system inside
the door was reportedly unlocked when
the Intruder apparently intoxicated
entered the home two weeks ago around 3
A.M Sullivan confronted the man and told
him to leave the Secret Service detail
outside did not know about the break-in
until Sullivan told them the man who
broke in has not been identified or
arrested the Secret Service said in a
statement that any deviation from our
protective protocols is unacceptable and
if discovered Personnel will be held
accountable security for high-level
government official has been under
scrutiny after several recent attacks
the husband of house Speaker Nancy
Pelosi was severely beaten with a hammer
in their San Francisco home in October
and earlier this week two Congressional
staffers were hospitalized after being
attacked and Congressman Jerry
Connolly's Virginia office Sullivan was
unharmed but the Secret Service says his
security has been stepped up the agents
on detail the night of the intrusion are
benched pending the investigation Gail
so many questions to that story
Catherine you have three Secret Service
agents outside and you're Jake Sullivan
your National Security advisor very very
troubling thank you so much yes